[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily an
eleven-year-old survivor of the uvalde
school shooting addresses congress with
an impassioned plea
he shot my friend that was next to me
and i
thought he was gonna come back to the
room so i grabbed the blood
and
put it all over me and as to the
defendant i say
you are a sexual predator the mega
church leader dubbed the apostle is
sentenced for years of sexual abuse plus
the murder of tara grinstead i think
there needs to be a very large
independent investigation into this case
into so many different elements of this
case we hear from ryan duke's defense
attorney and later danielle redlich
stands trial for the murder of her
stepfather turned husband the home that
she is standing in in this moment in
time
looks like something
from a horror movie and when she opens
the door of her hiding place
her whole world changed lawn crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer survivors
and parents of the victims of the deadly
mass shooting in uvalde texas which left
21 people dead are demanding action
taking their concerns before congress 19
students and two teachers were shot and
killed on may 24th when an 18 year old
gunman opened fire in the school 17
others were injured the gunman used an
ar-15 style rifle to shoot and injure
his grandmother before making his way to
the school he entered through an
unlocked side door and remained inside
for more than an hour as multiple
students inside the building called
9-1-1 he was later shot and killed by
border patrol agents police response to
the incident has been a point of
contention resparking nationwide
conversations about gun laws a couple
who lost their daughter in the shooting
delivered remarks via video conference
presenting a list of gun reform policy
changes to a house committee on
wednesday calling on congress to ban
assault rifles pass red flag laws and
install stronger background checks among
others an 11-year-old who survived the
shooting told the committee she doesn't
feel safe in school anymore
mia cerrillo shared her story recounting
covering herself in her classmate's
blood in order to appear dead when the
gunshots rang out
she went to lock the door and he was in
the hallway
and they made eye contact
and then she went to back in the room
and she showed us
go hide
then he shot the little window
and then he went to the other classroom
and then he went
there's a door between our classrooms
and he went to there and
saw my teacher and told my teacher
tonight and shot her in the head
when i went to the backs uh
he shot my friend that was next to me
and i
thought he was gonna come back to the
room so i grabbed the blood and
put it all on me
if there was something that you want
people to know about
that day and about you right
or things that you want different what
would it be
do you feel safe at school
why not
because i don't want it to happen again
i know i said it already but let that
sink in an 11 year old had the presence
of mind to choose life over death and
cover herself with her classmate's blood
just to survive
hoping for change here well joining us
today is criminal defense attorney mike
corbonis and co-host terry austin mike
one of the major pushes is to raise the
age for assault rifles or those type of
weapons from 18 to 21 but kentucky
representative james comer argued if an
18 year old in the military can have it
then a law-abiding 18-year-old should
also be does that make any sense
that is absolutely senseless dangerous
and reckless in my opinion
i i think that people in the military
are trained
they are in the military they have to
follow command they're not people who
are 18 on the street and things of that
nature i i wish that whoever wants to
say things like that would sit down and
let the parents of the people experience
this horror ask them questions and they
answer the questions those people have
rather than just spreading things that
look like the military isn't disciplined
and things of that nature it's a whole
different world the military and out in
the streets yeah let's get let's give 18
year olds tanks and rpgs that'll be fine
too terry this was an emotional
testimony do you think it will make a
difference
you know i do think it's making a
difference this was a divided house vote
that was influenced by this testimony
and also we also saw that there was a
pediatrician who also testified and he
said that the bodies of these children
were literally pulverized and
decapitated and ultimately the house did
pass in a very slim margin a law that
would ban some of these automatic rifles
and some of these large magazines but
listen it still has to go to the senate
and there's no guarantee at all
whatsoever that that's going to pass
well we'll be keeping eyes on that as it
progresses through the different
chambers thank you both still ahead on
law and crime daily weeks after an
acquittal in the murder of tara
grinstead we hear from ryan duke's
attorney but first a sentence is handed
down for the so-called apostle and
leader of the los angeles area mega
church
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back the so-called apostle the
los angeles area mega church is
sentenced to nearly 17 years in prison
on multiple counts of sexual assault
involving a minor
fifty-three-year-old naesano akin garcia
better known as the apostle led the las
velas lo del muno mega church and
claimed to be christ on earth
garcia had upwards of five million
followers multiple who he sexually
abused and assaulted prosecutors say
garcia used his power to abuse children
by recruiting congregants to abuse
children to have sex with him garcia
originally faced 23 counts of rape and
sex trafficking involving underage girls
at his congregation last week he pled
guilty and was convicted on three counts
at a sentencing hearing on wednesday
multiple of garcia's survivors gave
emotional victim impact statements
i keep finding myself wishing
that he had just killed me
because
at least then
i would be put out of my misery
that i feel now and i know
i will feel for the rest of my life
he nason joaquin
he took everything from me
he took away my family
he took away my
friends he took away my trust and my
innocence
and now all i'm left with are broken and
ugly pieces of memories of what he did
to me
for so many years
in the end the judge called garcia a
sexual predator saying his hands were
tied in giving a shorter sentence
i've never ceased to amaze
be amazed that what some people do
in the name of religion
and how lives are ruined in the guise
of serving a supreme being
as of the jane does
at this point
i apologize my hands are tied
lawyers
do what lawyers do at this point my
hands are tied but i further want to
tell all the jane does
that the world
has heard you
i promise you that
as to those family members
that have abandoned the jane does
shame
shame on you
and as to the defendant i say
you are a sexual predator
powerful words terry 16 counts dismiss
including a rape of a child and only
guilty on three accounts for
a little over 16 years
how and why does that work with these
facts
it is very difficult and you heard those
individuals in the courtroom crying when
the judge said what he had to say but
listen now we can avoid a long trial and
we have him pleading guilty to three
counts two forcible oral copulation on a
minor one count of committing a lewd act
on a minor it's a difficult case to
prosecute because the victims literally
were told that if they went against
garcia's desires they were going against
god and so putting them on the stand
would have been very difficult but
listen he has the support of the church
and again the prosecution would have a
hard time trying to prosecute this case
so i think the plea at the end of the
day really did make sense even though it
was difficult yeah mike families
protested a plea deal saying they were
only made aware of it in the last
minutes and the judge said as you saw
there that his hands were tied but can't
a judge reject a plea
a judge can reject the plea but i think
maybe one of the reasons his hands were
tied as terry pointed out is and i used
to be a former sex crimes prosecutor
when i was in the prosecutor's office is
that
some of the victims do not want to go
through this again and i think one of
the things that the prosecution took
into consideration with this we offer is
his age of 53 years old i believe
so a 16 year sentence that someone is 53
is probably the equivalent to a 30-year
sentence of somebody in their 30s or
around there so i think those are all
things that were taken into
consideration and that's what the judge
sort of may have felt his hands were
tied because if he didn't take it the
prosecution may run for some risk of
getting a conviction absolutely well he
is sentenced now and as i said he is a
sexual predator coming up on law and
crime daily opening statements are
presented in florida versus daniel
redling
plus fresh off her client's acquittal
for a murder charge ryan duke's attorney
sits down the lawn crime network
[Music]
welcome back for the first time we're
hearing from the attorney of ryan duke
just weeks after he was acquitted for
the murder of georgia beauty queen and
teacher tara grinstein long crime
network followed the case galvano gavel
as duke stood trial for grinstead's 2005
murder after grinstead went missing that
october her case went cold for more than
a decade in 2017 ryan duke and his
friend beau dukes were charged in
connection to her murder during last
month's trial ryan duke testified he
lied when confessing to grinstead's
murder but admitted to helping beau
dukes dispose of her body by burning it
in a pecan orchard in a nearby county
duke was acquitted of the murder but
ultimately convicted of concealing her
death he was sentenced to 10 years
duke now faces six new counts in
neighboring ben hill county including
concealing the death of another
hindering apprehension or punishment of
a criminal concealment of facts and
tampering with evidence beauduce also
faces charges in ben hill county the
trial for those charges is set to start
as early as the end of june but ashley
merchant attorney for ryan duke says
erwin county dropped the ball when
charging beau dukes in the crime
i hope that they take a very hard look
at bo i don't at this point though think
that they're going to charge him with
murder i think that what happened was
they chose the person that they were
going to to try to take the blame for
this ryan and that was the horse so to
speak and they they put all of their
eggs in that basket and they stuck with
that and now i think their credibility
if they were to charge bo would be very
very diminished because you know it
would be a built-in defense like didn't
you charge someone else with this murder
um it's unfortunate i had hoped that
they would choose a different path we um
we were able to find all of these women
that beau had victimized over the years
and all of these things that could be
brought in as what you'd call similar
transactions or prior bad acts and
presented those to the state and
presented them to the detective and and
were hoping that they would take a
second look at this and hoping that they
would change course and decide that
maybe ryan was not capable of doing this
and they had the wrong person they never
choose to do that i spoke with these
women and they explained these
encounters and they would be bondage
type situations strangulation type
situations things that the orchard
things that would be highly relevant
based on the facts of this case and that
the state could have investigated and
could have used had they chosen to to
investigate bo dukes but they didn't
they didn't go they didn't talk to these
people they didn't present them they
didn't present this case
they essentially put on blinders
terry can duke's words when he testified
in their irwin county case be used
against him in the ben hill county case
to try to convict him
they could be used against him certainly
we have to determine whether or not his
words are hearsay and you know hearsay
is an out of court statement asserted to
prove the truth of the matter and i do
think it would be hearsay but there are
exceptions to that prior inconsistent
statements and one of the things the
judge is going to have to determine is
whether or not this was more prejudicial
or probative listen he was subject to
cross-examination in the prior trial we
saw this being done in the durst case if
you remember a lot of the comments in
the former trials were admitted and so
it's possible his words could be used
against him yeah now mike do you think
the state of georgia is trying to add
more years to duke sentence by having
him tried in different counties because
they couldn't prove he murdered
grinstead and is that the right thing to
do
i think that could be one of the
strategies another strategy i think is
that the more they try in different
counties where they have
offenses that they can try that he's
charged with they may come up with more
evidence and open more doors to further
investigation and i wouldn't be
surprised if that occurs that if perhaps
the federal government may take over the
prosecution because then you have
a separate jurisdiction that can retry
him on similar facts for a murder
i mean they've got him in one county
they got him in a second i agree with
you maybe the fed's coming as well and
get a third uh kind of swing at bat so
to speak well we'll see how that
continues and of course give you
coverage here on the long crime daily
when we come back a florida woman stands
trial for the murder of her stepfather
turned husband still ahead we hear
opening statements from both sides
[Music]
welcome back to long crime daily opening
statements are presented in a florida
courtroom as a woman stands trial for
the stabbing death of her husband
when ex-nba executive michael redlich
died three years ago his wife danielle
redlich claimed he stabbed himself now
she says she killed him in self-defense
officials say the couple had a rocky
relationship which ended january 11 2019
with michael's death danielle is charged
with second-degree murder and tampering
with evidence in his stabbing death
9-1-1 calls reveal she initially told
dispatchers her husband stabbed himself
and had a heart attack after the two had
an altercation in opening statements
prosecutors told the jury dania waited
11 hours before calling for help while
perusing a dating app prosecutors
describe the scene in detail when
michael's body was found the morning of
january 12 2019
that defendant
plunged a knife into the shoulder
of michael redlich
which would cause him
to bleed to death
the evidence will show
that she engages in a
significant but failed attempt to clean
up the scene
you're going to see the photographs from
when law enforcement arrived everything
that mrs redlich did to try to avoid
responsibility to try to make this seem
like something that it wasn't
blood soaked towels
mops
soaked in blood
a five gallon bucket full of pinkish
water
the smell of cleaning fluid
striking the nose of the law enforcement
officers and csis that enter that home
throughout this case the evidence will
show that despite her many many many
claims that she had nothing to do with
this
in fact
she did
the defense attorney told jurors
danielle is the real victim and that she
was defending herself when she stabbed
michael as he tried to strangle her
danielle's attorney described what she
says happened the night michael
died after mcdonald's she heads home
and michael is there
he is pounding down the vodka
he grabs her food and then he goes at
her
he is in a rage and this rage is the
angriest that she has ever seen him he
pushes her down she goes to her knees he
pulls her up by the hair he shoves her
to the kitchen island he chokes he
smothers her
she reaches into her drawer she grabs a
knife
she stabs him one time
he is stunned
he releases her and she runs to the
bathroom she waits until it's safe for
her to come out
and when she opens the door of her
hiding place
her whole world changed
all right mike
former prosecutor coreobonics break down
the prosecution's opening for us what
should we expect in their case and do
you see any holes in it so far
well i think their case is going to be
very methodical and they're going to
have to show all the consist
inconsistencies in her statement i think
this prosecutor seems very comfortable
in his opening and the way he addresses
the jury and i think that's going to be
very helpful in the way they're going to
have to go through a lot of evidence
here because i'm sure there was a lot of
things with blood and things of that
nature but i think they're going to have
to
the defense is going to have to explain
about this choking because she went to a
hospital i hope they have an expert to
show that she was choked
hey maybe the prosecution brings up the
guys that she matched with on the dating
app that could be evidence too but terry
the defense's opening was interesting to
say the least from what i hear it sounds
like she may testify but let's put that
aside for a second do you think it
raises any reasonable doubt with the
jury in explaining what happened you
know i do think that the defense's
opening raised some doubt whether or not
it was reasonable what i think is the
prosecution put on a you know statement
and you really felt as though wow it had
to be the way the prosecution is saying
it because she lied several times she
said at first he had a heart attack then
she said he stabbed himself and now
she's claiming self-defense that alone
is going to make the jury wonder but the
defense really did paint a picture of
her being an abused wife and saying that
the husband was an alcoholic that he was
violent and i think that that is
something for the jury to think about
maybe they haven't convinced themselves
already let's hope they keep an open
mind that's what they need to do and
perhaps she does have a viable
self-defense argument here so we'll have
to see what the evidence shows so far
we've seen lots of witnesses who are
police officers and there is a lot of
evidence as we've just said yeah with
that opening though it suggests the only
way they get that evidence in is that
she testifies well we'll see well thank
you for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
you